ha this is their like they're just
looking fire no I don't know who
markiplier is here
what uh what hi
uh what hi what would you kitties like
for Christmas this year I want I want
your body more my body you want sailors
fat body or you can't have it when you
have a Merry Christmas all right you too
chi Chi you can hear can you hear me I'm
screaming for two men yet maybe ever
hear me well ho ho hold all that crap
you're a bear Christmas okay what hope
to hold markiplier you make me smile
like every day oh thank you
fast arrow the warmth canis don't cold
hard to hear that big this is so just
such an honor you know you just made my
holiday happy birthday happy birthday
all the kitties need to die I hope you
have a good day that day you must not
get a lot of presents on your birthday
if Christmas is freaking hard I do
oh you know what you lucky loser huh
hello what what huh what what's going on
why God why
okay what would you like I thought
Merck play while bar bars out here but I
could give yourself I've looked away
Rome how is that easy section north
apart no I don't know who are Cabarrus
buttocks down a clause if you know what
I mean I'm just wearing this jerk for no
reason ah knows what the hell is douche
doing here ah fighting you stole all
your chance you after the doctor person
without going on
what do you offer took a little boy yeah
did it no girl hell I can give you job I
got a good company
it's like my my my right like I don't I
can't say it's too much for it wanna be
everywhere oh I found you I'm like the
happiest man oh wow happy that bark bark
could help you out don't you run away
from death then I'll come find you
I don't where you live oh oh my house in
hospital a lot and I just remember you
know upset it sucks but it would have
been made so much better if I had a game
console to do something on Vesta we have
your Noah bring it to other kids
seriously it's absolutely amazing oh
thank you so much I really appreciate
that you even made me break character
how dare you oh hi how are you guys
the oil would you two like for Chris
ballinger I got my wish fulfilled oh
come on Santa Claus walk could
appreciate that your water black dildo
enough to give you a knuckle pretty good
Dan a killed all of us out all of it
kind of kid how are you doing Santa
what's got all voices that I all don't
like you're doing there are you making
fun of Santa Claus
oh said I'm sorry I want to make sure
I'm on the nice list
yeah you better cuz love them colder
Zweig up your ass don't feel too good
now do that
I think markiplier is the best youtuber
on the Internet
Wow he's a lazy [ __ ] but I'll tell
him you said that nice beard not quite
as luxurious despise oh you're
everyone's jealous of Santa's beard when
he left we're gonna save jingle bells
okay I'm really good at that I said mrs.
nutmeg nothing guys Wow my later
ding dammit Oh giggle ball giggle mom oh
holy dad my whole goat kitty and aren't
you can call it a pile of poop hey what
would you like for Christmas in jail I
would live in unicorn as well you know
card don't exist Danner killed the last
one to get his blood in and rig it so
that Danner could live forever sorry to
break this to you I thought that was
foldable so I've looked who's just Egret
Voldemort didn't actually die I picked
up a contract for another job
yeah story I grew the beard to hide by
non nose I know I'm hello hey are you
yeah hey how's it going oh whoa hello
good hello I need to Buffy yeah I'm
surprised you actually found you
but yeah Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
just let me save a bit Hey it's really
you okay I'm gonna keep watching your
videos I'm so happy oh you're amazing
you're great you're a sweetheart I said
all this stuff before man you make it
awesome yeah I hope to meet you our best
YouTube I hope to meet you in real life
someday thank you so much just don't let
you do with the lines I'm going through
hopefully and we're ready
oh they're never happy Christmas from
the United Kingdom oh well thank you so
much we still Merry Christmas to Merc
yeah yeah but you have a good one okay
thank you so much hi hi how's it going
oh my god I'm looking for you for so
long
tummy time all right Oh some water I
showed her your videos like last year
because they were helping me through a
really hard time in my lifetime I I
showed her that oh oh you're frozen oh
no no no oh no no come on oh where is
the only Rolly I found him Wow You Know
Who I am I am Optimus Claus
I bring presents to the Autobots around
here really Wow yes I wish that could I
hang on maybe I could bust her up just a
little bit of Santa Claus for you
because this would be perfect my voice
is kind of shot but I can I think I can
do one more okay
putting the Santa our little Korea I am
Optimus Claus Optimus cause a no yes I
am no gaggle on there girl everyone I am
your father did your eyes just go at
different direction yeah that's
incredible you can actually hear it boy
crap I am so lucky
oh my god thank you so this made my
Christmas dude that's really did they're
really I'm so happy
hey guys I hope you enjoyed this video
it was a lot of fun to make and I really
do enjoy talking to you guys I'm sorry
about all the problems that happened to
me losing my voice as you can tell it's
all better now you don't need to worry
about it I'm doing just fine my cords
bounce back pretty quickly um just thank
you guys so much I hope you have a happy
holidays and a Merry Christmas whatever
you felt
it doesn't matter I'm just so grateful
that you guys have been with me for so
long so I want to do these more I really
love interacting with the fans and just
being standard for you guys and I like I
made so many people laugh like right
right then and there and I was so happy
to do that um it won't always be Santa
of course but this is one opportunity to
do it I'm really grateful for that so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart
you guys thank you so much for joining
me thank you so much for supporting and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye hey boy